con el inicio de la temporada de verano
en francia hay una ligera sensación de
precaución en el aire no nos queremos
enfermar durante nuestras vacaciones así
que llevamos mascarillas comandó en el
tren es mejor tener cuidado con el aire
acondicionado no soy partidaria de tomar
precaución algunos se preguntan si
podrían volver algunas restricciones no
sabemos cuál va a ser la situación
dentro de 3 o 4 semanas pero tiene buena
pinta creo vamos a ver qué hace el
gobierno español
de momento el uso de la mascarilla no es
obligatorio en el transporte público
pero se recomienda encarecidamente con
una media de unos 99 mil casos diarios
eso supone un aumento del 60% en sólo
una semana una cifra que en opinión de
este experto médico debería impulsar la
adopción de medidas más estrictas y más
todo lo mío volver a poner las
mascarillas en los lugares donde más se
propaga el virus sería lo más eficaz
creemos que el transporte público un
espacio cerrado en el que te cruzas con
mucha gente y en el que es imposible
rastrear los contactos está
contribuyendo a la propagación de este
virus volver a poner las mascarillas
tiene un efecto inmediato
un consejo que mucha gente está harta de
escuchar después de dos años los
estadounidenses vuelven a parís para
estos turistas el cob y de es lo último
en lo que piensan las tengo pero no me
las pongo queremos visitar francia
consell cobit se acabó para nosotros ya
no las llevo estamos vacunados y nos
sentimos
el gobierno francés dice que por ahora
no hay medidas drásticas sobre la mesa